[Music]
thank you for coming down
yeah well just following orders I cannot
see mmm-hmm exactly right well you're in
the country so what we're going to do go
ahead whoring and Soho yeah that
would've been the first choice well look
Kendall's gone to the pub apparently so
I've just had a little bit of pidgin
done didn't think anyone would be
feeling terribly hungry I know I'm not
know right don't wonder great course not
I've got some gubbins great thank you so
how are you I might just we'll ask you
if you can't go into all that it wasn't
intended as an aggressive question mom
it's no I'm fine
Rory's wonderful mm-hmm so should I be
mother
yeah why don't you give it a go
yes I'm sorry it's not a 48 ounce t-bone
steak with truffle fries but there we go
some of us don't want coronary heart
attacks nice mine's nice it's quite a
lot of shot in the pigeon so mind how
you go in crack a tooth and the shot can
take a bit of feather in - mm-hmm should
we begin with the negotiation
straightaway first time I've had you in
from the night in a decade it's just a
shame it's so you can put the squeeze on
me for your father it's not like that
no no tell me what does it feel like
being sent here to wheel out your mother
don't look at me I'm not getting
involved she's right well thank you
thank you but a solidarity
20 years too late never mind someone's
taking mummys side yep if you want to
get into it you're just posturing right
if you go with sandy and Stewie you're
burning down the Colosseum with your
children inside it
I've sold your budget I discussed it
with Rory yeah well great to get his
brain on it
potatoes he's actually rather clever you
know before he rolls one of his tobacco
and hash monstrosities God sorry what
was that
nothing mum there's a number ah here we
go
the chiseling begins this will be good
how much could we screw out of our dear
old mother called dad unrelated to the
vote of course is willing to reopen the
divorce settlement so what's the number
well what do you want I want to piss off
your father well I think that's working
mm-hmm come on help yourselves all right
then come on
what's his top number well he told me to
tell you 10 but it's 40 so it's 50 no no
it's 40 I'm not very good at this
no what's the real top he doesn't have
the real top dad never gone I know what
I'd like tell him the Summer Palace
the Hamptons has no hater out there yeah
but he loves it doesn't he
you know ups the parties the clam bakes
with people who despise him such
fabulous it's like what is that it's
like 115 million it doesn't matter realm
it's his numbers I'll have a word with
Jack the Ulsterman too and throw that in
okay
what or how about 20 million and you
kids give me Christmas every year oh
come on well I'm gonna make it like I
would like to come for Christmas
sure no you never invite us because
you've made it quite clear you wouldn't
come
that was one time that was several times
I was 18
look I would like to see you for
Christmas
instead of you always being with your
father why don't you ask him what he'd
rather he will keep the summer palace if
I get the family every Christmas you
have to have good lines of communication
after a divorce it's absolutely key so I
think we have to hear which he'd prefer
let's make him choose
you